Now that we've got our performance captured and we understand the whole pipeline of using
the virtual camera, let's talk about how to edit our sequences within Sequencer.
So a Sequencer allows for the trimming, editing and manipulation of keyframes and animation
curves captured within the take recorder.
So again, we've got all this data now captured from the live performance.
And now we can go in here and clean it up.
So anything from the virtual camera moves to a rig inversion animation derived from
recorded performance capture data.
So the performance capture takes control rig animations, virtual camera movement, live
folly, anything that you added to the take recorder essentially will all be visible within
here and allows you to really dial in on the specific keys.
And you can open the curve editor as well using this button here.
So that opens your curve editor, which is this larger window if you really want to dial
in some of these keys.
And then you can also finalize the recordings with the Sequencer editorial tools.
So edit the recorded takes with the curve editor, save the takes as a new level sequence,
and then the level sequences can be added as sub-scene tracks which we touched upon in
previous courses.
There's documentation on the sub-scene tracks if you're unsure what they are and it allows
you to set camera binding ID in the camera cuts.
We can create sub-scene tracks in Sequencer.
We can add the V cam track in the timeline and then also adjust the shot duration for
the final edit.
So all of these can be edited within Sequencer.